multiplayer games can tell great stories
so please let them let's talk about it
[Music]
why are we talking about multiplayer
storytelling in video game uh because of
the story of the week which was a
revelation from blizzard that the hero
modes for OverWatch 2 are not going to
be released in the form that we saw them
having a separate Co-op or single player
narrative driven experience that
involves taking characters pushing them
through like a skill tree a talent tree
and power progression and that kind of
stuff the thing that most of us were
excited about when they announced
OverWatch too and the thing that they
Justified the two on OverWatch with so
we had an interview with uh blizzard a
couple of Aaron Keller and Jared news
from the team and kind of talked about
it and you can read that interview on
gamespot.com now they are going to tell
the story
through seasonal events which is
something that they have been doing
since the start of OverWatch so the
announcement for lack of a better phrase
foiled a lot of piss a lot of piss was
boiled piss was boiling people were
Furious I'm wearing my OverWatch Socks
today actually
I'm wearing my OverWatch underwear
does that exist you'll never know
dig into that but people
are very much afraid
to the Wayside but we are here to talk
about the fact that multiplayer games
can tell great meaningful stories so the
reason as we mentioned we're talking
about this is because it feels like a
lot of squandered potential it feels
like we're being once again kept away
from the thing that we want most out of
OverWatch which is the story and now
that we know it's going to be told
through the seasonal events it's making
behind the season pass behind the season
pass the format of it is kind of
worrying
um so we've been thinking a lot about
multiplayer games and the stories they
tell and start to think about is it
possible to do good ones and the kind of
where we reach was yes you can
definitely do a good multiplayer story
right yes absolutely but I think you
know when we were talking through some
of the examples a lot of them haven't
really
hit off the bat so you look at Destiny
yeah oh the story of my original text
you like grimoire cards wasn't even told
in the game itself had some incredible
cutscenes uh I think we'll remember that
wizard came from the moon but eventually
Destiny caught on to the fact that yeah
you know loot uh numbers going up
Etc is going to bring people back but
you know what else brings people back
story and characters that people can
connect to and I think with Destiny 2
especially uh like some of the later
expansions that's when they really
knuckle down and it's become a huge
movement yeah and I think that that's
the kind of trend that you hope it would
be a trend but it hasn't caught on as a
trend which is also why we're talking
about it right like there's a lot of
multiplayer games where the story just
doesn't feel substantial like cards like
Call of Duty what is that for like okay
we're gonna tease up yeah an import zone
map or something but then you take
something like apex apex is doing a good
job of it but still it's very similar to
OverWatch in terms of the way it's told
is almost feels like a drip feed of it
yeah through like events cinematic
trailers the games that do it really
well along with Destiny Final Fantasy
XIV and MMO as if that was weak as we
call it here that is perhaps the best
example of what a story a good story can
do to your multiplayer experience the
original version of the game a mess for
many many reasons just a nightmare of a
game they like destroyed that world as a
narrative part of the actual game like
that was part it was an event we
destroyed the world and then they
rebuilt it as A Realm Reborn and focused
on story and characters above almost
above everything else everything else is
kind of like it's got good classes new
classes mechanically but it's it plays
like an MMO for the most part but the
thing that fans constantly talk about
and now to put Michael Heim on blast
yeah the story the characters those
moments I have watched many a stream of
Final Fantasy players breaking down in
tears at a narrative moment that is the
kind of experience that you'd expect or
if you are some random Gamers they'll
probably expect that from the mainline
Final Fantasy games not the multiplayer
one so it's definitely a huge Boon for
it and then fortnite is the other one
right like
fortnite ostensibly shooting game right
but run away yeah run away from run away
from eight-year-olds yeah run away from
eight-year-old games yeah they make a
story out of everything like we have the
season transitions which is always like
wild and wacky but now they have like
you know I think that character was
named Zero or something like that the
one that The Rock played oh yeah yeah
like that was a whole thing and whenever
they do like license thing things they
they make a big deal about the Ariana
Grande concert that is basically just
high level capitalism happening in front
of us right like epic games like we've
got this thing that everyone loves
Ariana Grande is like we want to reach
exchange monies and contracts and here
we go but in the game it was a narrative
thing there was a narrative around it
people tuned in or they they felt the a
reason to come back to it and kind of
experience what it is and the other one
is Warframe oh yeah Warframe is one of
those games along with ziv that I wish I
had the time to invest into it because
that Community just loves it so so much
and seeing how they've managed to
maintain that community over so many
years like 10 years at this point is
nothing short of incredible and Warframe
grew in player base like exponentially
over time and you can almost chart its
investment in story and characters
alongside that growth they clearly
understood that this is why this is
something that people want to get
invested in and come back OverWatch one
we played because we enjoyed it right we
reached now we reach the point where
mechanically it's not you know rustling
our jimmies or whatever you want to say
that means that means annoying you
annoying me
um it's not particularly pickle tickling
your pickle I said I was gonna say
tickling your grapes
the thing that we want now is the world
the characters OverWatch is taking a lot
of else a lot of L's so for
clothing
all of obviously all of the issues are
blizzard uh we're also talking about the
fact that they sunset at the original
game the 6v6 changed the mode from yeah
6v6 to 5v5 they lost uh control Point
Maps uh including some absolute fan
favorites like hanamura yeah then we're
talking about the season pass content
which has been like I feel like it's
been they've been delivering what they
set out to do there's a lot of content
however a lot of issues with new Heroes
yeah we're at a point now where
OverWatch to a new camera is very very
difficult to get into because you're
looking at 35 Heroes OverWatch one that
you could see the exact moment they
pulled out like they they were like done
they were doing minimal minimal work and
the justification for that they've been
very open it's like we were working on a
much bigger game so there was a
multi-year Content drought around
OverWatch like two years it was like
three years two to three years and that
drought was due to the fact that they
were working on new content for the
sequel and and now we've reached the
point where none of that is coming out
in the way that we expected it which
means they we sat through the content
drought we suffered through it for no
reason and I think it's important to
note that while the main PVE hero
missions is gone yeah there has been
some miscommunication or at least
misinterpretation from a lot of places
where they're like oh PVE has gone
entirely no it's not no they're gonna
put that into the season passes in the
battle pass yeah and that's it's gonna
be seasonal content I'm not excited by
that method of delivery of story to make
that investment the character and and
story investment you need to give people
something to latch on to and a
sprinkling of narrative isn't enough and
that's what it looks like they're going
to be doing with these with these like
seasonal sort of things because they now
have to take the story that they want to
tell or were going to tell but it still
needs to fit into the framework that
currently exists unless they're going to
change entirely how they deliver content
on a seasonal basis which they're not it
doesn't look like it we're gonna get
these small packets of story which don't
feel satisfying at all one thing that
OverWatch has in its back pocket that I
think has been squandered particularly
over the last couple years is
over investment into do Esports because
you are catering there to the high
skilled players and the people who want
to watch essentially a sport whereas
they could take a leaf out of League of
Legends and Riot's book and lean more
into the transmedia part of things which
is you know League of Legends has a
multitude of different games set in
their Universe they have a K-pop band
they have Arcane on Netflix and
OverWatch has Comics don't get me wrong
and the occasional cinematics RS
cinematic but there is so much more you
can do in that world because then you
are appealing to a much more casual for
the lack of a better term you are
appealing to a casual audience who are
then having an investment in your world
and that's how you can bring them in and
I would love to see them take the money
that they keep trying to put in into
Esports to make that a thing again or
make it bigger and just put that back
into OverWatch as a IP like expanding
its Horizons I think as you said League
of Legends is doing it perfectly like
cyberpunk did it one time really really
well but the impact of it was massive
right like Riot Forge is what they I
think they call it which is like the
umbrella where they start they've been
releasing spin-off uh League of Legends
games and I think that is something that
OverWatch
needs to embrace getting a team an
outside third party developer that can
make a single player game and let them
make it it could be something completely
different the riot games are
mechanically not mobas like they're just
like has a side-scrolling action game
but it's set in that world and it has
characters or touchstones from that
world they expand how people see that
world and there's so much potential in
OverWatch to do that but they just never
do it they just leave it and cyberpunk
did the thing with the Netflix series
and the impact of that was player base
went it like skyrocketed and this is a
game that had a
bad uphill struggle and the lingering
kind of sentiment around it wasn't
particularly good but like once they
released that edge Runners thing it was
a whole different group of people
playing now or people coming back to it
and then they put his David's uh like
jacket or something in the game and it
was like back and forth yeah so you get
a DLC for the game for to reward the new
players who have come in with the show
it makes so much and like obviously
making business decisions we just we're
big fans of OverWatch we have
interviewed the OverWatch team many
times we even made a documentary series
about the OverWatch League when it first
started like I'm wearing OverWatch socks
man I'm not going to put that on oh
watch underwear
we're not going to put either of those
on camera for free
subscribe to my only times
um but yeah it is mind-boggling to me
that OverWatch has existed as long as it
has and its popularity is I'm gonna be
maybe controversial the only reason it
became a cultural Zeitgeist was because
of everything around it people's
obsessions with characters and how that
manifested and how did that manifest in
like fan art cosplay rule 32 34 34 34 um
I hate that I corrected you
um stories that people are doing but
things that fans love so much about it
that they took it upon themselves to
like represent that in new ways
multiplayer games they have the
potential to tell interesting stories
and OverWatch should be that's that
franchise that does it but they're just
not doing it and it's heartbreaking as
fans yeah it's a blizzard please please
here I'll play just let someone else
make your single player games you know
Insomniac presents the diva game I don't
oh
respawn respawn you're not getting
Titanfall but you will get a Mech for
Diva fall and like let them make that
you've done the hard part you've made
the universe that people want to be in
please let them let them give them new
ways in you will earn money and you'll
keep being part of the cultural
zeitgeist
and people will be happy about it we'll
be happy about it I'll be happy about it
thank you everyone for watching if
you've got hot takes about OverWatch 2
dropping its PVE let us know in the
comments below if you find me on Twitter
I'm at Lucy James games I'm at tomorrow
H oh
and we will see you next week for
another episode of spot on
if this
what are you doing it's High Noon